take the voice the construction elevator
up to the roof of One World Trade Center
and you're treated to a close-up look at
the spire taking the building to its
symbolic 1,776 feet
the spire is going to be a permanent
iconic part of the Manhattan skyline
below the building is at what Port
Authority executive director Patrick Roy
calls the punch list babe the core and
shell are complete and he's ticking off
final items before delivery I just
renovated my apartment so I bet you guys
punch with trusses but my apartment
looked a lot more done than this when I
was doing the punch list so this wood is
protecting the material on the other
side
the floors are among the last things
that are going to be put in you can see
the lobby and the marble in the lobby
which is spectacular
boy and everyone involved in rebuilding
at the 16 acre site close to putting
behind them years of infighting over
cost overruns and control of the project
between poised predecessors state and
city officials and Silverstein
Properties owner of the other World
Trade Center buildings within the next
year 1 & 4 World Trade will open 5.3
million square feet of brand-new
commercial space welcoming office
workers back to Ground Zero for the
first time since 9/11 I'm standing on
the 56th floor terrace of four World
Trade Center obviously spectacular view
of the Freedom Tower behind me as
progress is finally being made on this
project twelve years after the attacks
of 9/11
janno Lieber with silverstein says that
the project is gaining momentum it's
truly an exciting moment when the World
Trade Center is turning from a bit of a
controversy to truly reclaiming its
place as a business center
One World Trade Center is 60% leased
with publisher Conde Nast as its anchor
tenant much of four will be the New Port
Authority headquarters between them the
two enormous pools that serve as
memorial to the twin towers plus an
active construction site the downtown
workers have to trek around the entire
project has a long way to go a memorial
museum is also slated to open in 2014
more office space and ambitious transit
hub and a Frank gehry-designed
Performing Arts Center may not be
completed for four to five years after
when these commercial buildings start
turning a profit for their owners these
projects have never been restricted
about money making our organization lost
some people on 9/11 it's obviously a
real estate project and it has to be
successful but it's also a civic mission
the answer is they will make money but
we have a little ways to go on